pas bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour
cette petite vidéo débriefing sur des
bonnes kg pénitence numéro 7 sur la
terre des dinosaures petite vidéo que je
sors aujourd'hui parce que demain il ya
star wars qui sort et que plus personne
ne va s'intéresser aux dinosaures
pendant à peu près trois semaines
donc voilà je vais probablement faire
une miniature en conséquence un petit
truc bien plus ta clique voilà ça va
être mignon ça va être sympa donc voilà
c'est cette vidéo débriefing elle va
être surtout certainement pas pour
m'excuser d'avoir ruiné de votre enfance
bien sûr mais en fait parce que du coup
que j'ai critiqué un reportage qui fait
autorité apparemment qui fait encore
autorité depuis 1999 c'est quand même
assez fou voilà on m'a demandé de
répondre intelligemment 1 et
constructivement en font en fournissant
des recommandations on va dire qu'elle
quel genre de documentaire est ce que je
recommanderais 6 sur la terre des
dinosaures n'est pas conseillé bon j'ai
interdit à personne de regarder sur la
terre des dinosaures d'abord vous avez
tout à fait le droit de continuer c'est
juste que moi j'aime pas voilà c'est
tout
voilà mais du coup bah voila je vais
vous proposer une petite sélection de
reportages qui m'ont touché
et dieu sait que ça n'a pas été simple
parce que bas parce que je regarde pas
les reportages voilà et en plus comme
j'habite pas en france je ne regarde pas
les reportages en français donc les
reportages que je connais ils sont en
anglais et souvent ils sont même pas
sortis en france où ils sont sortis avec
un titre tellement différent que
j'arrive pas à les retrouvez donc bref
ça n'a pas toujours été simple
ça n'a pas toujours été simple mais
voilà je vais quand même vous proposer
une petite sélection voilà qui vous
amusera pendant les fêtes et qui vous
j'espère vous en jalles ira alors déjà
avant de commencer avec ce qu'il faut
regarder je vais commencer déjà par vous
dire ce qu'il ne faut pas regarder alors
je vous conseille dans tout ce que vous
pourrez sélectionner comme reportage
d'éviter tout ce qui est reportage
discovery channel et history channel
pourquoi parce qu'ils font du caca parce
que c'est nul ce qu'ils font donc
discovery channel c'est les coupables de
tous ces reportages débile genre un mec
qui combat un anaconda hamel et les
reportages sur les sirènes enfin les
faux reportage sur les sirènes les faux
reportage sur le loch ness les voilà
allez donc tous les documentaires bidon
quoi ça vient de discovery channel donc
et globalement ce qui est signée
discovery channel ça pulse
sensationnalisme c'est vraiment pas les
trucs que je que je recommande
et oui je sais ce que vous allez me dire
mais moi j'ai vu un reportage qui était
bien
sur discovery channel ouais c'est une
généralité voilà si vous voulez de la
bonne facture évitez discovery channel
c'est une généralité
je dis pas qu'ils en ont pas fait une
fois de temps en temps est correct je
veux dire même les meilleurs voyant non
pas la prétention de se planter à chaque
fois comme disait voltaire
voilà donc enfin même les pires voyant
non pas la prétention de se planter à
chaque fois donc voilà discovery channel
à force de mitrailler ils ont
certainement dû faire des bons
reportages mais bon voilà c'est juste
des probabilités
on a tous le droit à 5 % d'erreurs et
history channel basse et les
responsables de la lienne théorie donc
règne pour ça n'y allez pas voilà c'est
aussi le responsable de jurassic fight
club aussi voilà donc ça vous placent le
niveau un peu de history channel donc
non je vous recommande pas du tout voilà
si vous regardez un reportage et que
d'un seul coup vous voyez production
discovery channel ou production qui
street chanel voilà vous savez que vous
pouvez changer de chaîne globalement
vous allez rien apprendre
globalement c'est du caca donc voilà
quels sont les reportages que je
conseillerai et ben le premier se serait
planète dinosaures planète dinosaures
alors en plus c'est pareil planète
dinosaures il a quand même un gros
problème c'est qu'il ya discovery
channel qui a fait un truc qui s'appelle
dinosaures planète donc planète
dinosaures faut pas se tromper c'est
c'est celui qui a été fait par la bbc
qu'il faut regarder donc il a été
diffusé sur france 4 et alors vous voyez
les avantages de planètes dinosaures
c'est qu'il vous montre les fossiles
voilà donc là ce n'est qu'un extrait que
j'ai trouvé sur youtube
mais bon si vous cherchez bien vous
finirez par les trouver les planètes
dinosaures soit sur youtube soit sur
dailymotion et c'est trés c'est très
intéressant parce que voilà ça vous
montre justement les fossiles sur
lesquels sont basés les belles histoires
qu'il vous raconte
et ça c'est ce que je reproche du coup à
sur la terre des dinosaures qui ne vous
montre pas les fossiles sur lesquels
sont basés les histoires qu'il vous
raconte
donc là on vous montre le spinosaures et
vous le montre en plus en nous montrant
que lolo type est pas la reconstruction
kaka que j'ai critiqué aussi dans mon
épisode sur la terre des dinosaures
voilà donc c'est très pédagogique j'aime
beaucoup et même si évidemment ce tous
les aucun reportage n'est exempt
d'erreurs ou de simplification aucun et
j'en suis tout à fait conscient c'est
juste que au moins là vous savez sur
quoi ça
si vous voyez une erreur vous savez d'où
elle vient par exemple planète
dinosaures ils ont toutes un épisode sur
un petit animal dont ils disent qu'il
était qu'il l'était venimeux me voilà
c'est le synhorcat aux russes donc qui
avait une
une morsure venimeuse selon eux est
alors le fait est que oui il en parle
alors que c'est probablement faux je le
dire maintenant il ya eu un article
publié en 2009 je crois qu'il disait que
c'était faux mais au moins ils vous
montrent que ça sort pas de nulle part
voyez bon alors ça c'est voilà il vous
montre le fossile et sur le fossile il
vous montre l'oeil
il vous montre ils vont vous montrer
aussi où se trouve la cavité de
venimeuse voilà donc au moins là il vous
montre le fossile il vous montre où il
pense que la cavité venimeuse enfin la
cavité qui contenait la glande à venin
se trouvait donc bref au moins les trucs
qui vous racontent ne sortent pas de
nulle part alors après vous vous pouvez
voir par vous même si vous avez si vous
pensez que oui ou non ça peut être une
glande à venin qui se trouvait là dans
ces petits trous l'on voit les petites
roues juste ici voilà donc ça au moins
voilà ça permet de se faire une bonne
idée de ski de ce sur quoi les belles
histoires qu'on vous raconte sont basés
et donc vous et ça vous permet aussi de
voir immédiatement que le reste est
inventé parce que il y à l'histoire
qu'on vous raconte avec le fossile qu'on
vous montre et il ya l'histoire qu'on
voit raconte sans rien vous montrer et
du coup ça permet par inférence de
savoir que le reste est basse et du
voilà c'est c'est dur commence et c'est
de la fiction donc au moins on sait la
part de fiction et on sait la part de
deux documentaires danser docu fiction
et voilà donc planète dinosaures avec la
bbc pas le dinosaure planète de
discovery channel 2 les deux noms se
ressemblent ça fait un peu penser aux
vous savez quand il ya les films pacific
rim qui sort il ya le film atlantique
rim qui sort en même temps et le
atlantique crime il est pourri alors que
le pacific rim c'est le sait le vrai
blockbuster réalisé avec des vrais
moyens donc là ça fait penser un peu à
ça il ya la bbc qui sort le vrai
reportage il ya discovery channel qui
vous sort le reportage moisi à côté qui
essayent de banque et sur le succès de
l'autre portage bref je m'égare encore
sur des analogies cinématographique
voilà donc ça c'est le premier reportage
que je suggère dinosaures planète
planète dinosaures de la bbc c'est du
bon et même s'il ya des choses qui sont
pas forcément consensuel on va dire et
bien au moins ça a le mérite
ça a le mérite d'être expliquer en quoi
c
ça pourrait être vrai ou faux tenez à
bâtonnets on voit les mêmes les dans la
regarder voilà la petite glande à venin
les dents avec le l'espèce de sion qui
guidait le venin selon les auteurs de
cette théorie donc voilà au moins c'est
clair
reportage suivant celui qui m'a le plus
marqué je pense de la sélection c'est
bonjour l'ancêtre ces décès des vieux
reportage
bonjour l'ancêtre cd vieux reportage qui
qui était animée par francis duranthon
donc éminent paléontologues toulousain
donc voilà francis duranthon qui a écrit
aussi des bouquins beaucoup de bouquins
dont l'histoire des dinosaures histoire
de dinosaures et un bouquin qui
s'appelle histoire de mammifères donc
que je vous recommande aussi ces deux
livres voilà et francis duranthon donc
c'est lui qui a fait toute une série de
reportages qui s'appelle bonjour
l'ancêtre et que vous pouvez retrouver
sur cette chaîne eric how i roll parce
qu'apparemment voyez à nant et lee ambi
ailier en bis qui a posté le plus de
reportages bonjour l'ancêtre donc et
peut-être même en meilleure qualité
non parce que eric how i roll l1 n'a
posté qu'un mais par contre et lee ambi
elle en a posté plusieurs là et donc les
bons jours l'ancêtre l'avantagent sais
que ça vous raconte des choses de la
paléontologie mais française donc c'est
que tous ou presque se passe en france
dans bonjour l'ancêtre et ça c'est quand
même cool parce que ça quand même l'
avantage de vous montrer le registre
fossile qu'on a chez nous vous voyez par
exemple ici je crois qu'il nous montre
des ichtyosaures un an
là il est à pierrelatte dans la ferme
aux crocodiles je crois qu'à un moment
il nous montre des ichtyosaures en plus
c'est du matos qui il me semble n'a
jamais été publié bref ya un moment dans
les reportages où ils vous parlent
dicter aux ors et en fait c'est
ichthyosaures il s'est tellement enfin
voilà le reportage est tellement
intéressant qu'il vous montre même des
choses qui sont pas encore publiés quoi
qui était pas publié à l'époque et qui
sont peut-être même pas encore publié
aujourd'hui donc ça c'est quand même
vachement intéressant et moi moi c'est
vraiment un reportage qui m'a fasciné
alors oui c'est un peu vieillot oui
c'est en 4/3 mai
voilà si vous aimez vraiment la
paléontologie vous aimez ce qui est
vieux et voilà et lâché des pousses
bleus voilà lâché 10 pouces bleus sur
ces petites vidéos parce qu'elles le
valent bien
voilà donc oui bonjour l'ancêtre
vraiment ça a été le gros coup de coeur
c'est ma plus grosse recommandations et
l' avantage c'est qu'il en à plat sur
youtube vous voyez les bonjours
l'ancêtre il y en a là y en a là un
petit alexis rastier au milieu je vous
recommande aussi alexandre astier s'est
il fait des très bonne vidéo
par contre si c'est pour vos gamins
m'ont peut-être pas alexis rastier parce
que c'est quand même un peu pointu ce
qui dit alexis salut alexis je sais que
tu regarde cette vidéo
voilà je recommande alexis mais alors
c'est si vous voulez vraiment en
apprendre beaucoup en très peu de temps
alexis rassier c'est l'exact opposé d'un
documentaire standard s'est énormément
d'informations très peu de temps alors
que les documentaires c'est très très
peu d'informations dilater sur des
kilomètres de bandes vidéo
donc voilà donc vous voyez plein de bon
jour l'ancêtre et c'est que ou presque
que du registre fossile français donc
c'est vraiment vraiment très intéressant
puisqu'on parle de registre fossile
français je signale au passage la sortie
de ces toujours pas sorcier donc le déjà
le retour de c'est pas sorcier avec un
nouveau titre c'est toujours pas sorcier
et cette vidéo que la réserve naturelle
sainte victoire a mis en ligne sur
facebook
que reste-t-il des dinosaures on voit la
sfo quoi
il ya notamment enfin il ya des petites
erreurs il ya des coquilles qui se
glisse ici et là c'est pas ce pommeau
bien bien méchant mais vous voyez en
face et des erreurs du genre à un moment
ils montrent assez l'office
est-ce que je vais arriver le retrouver
à un moment il montre à celle au
physique et ils disent qu'il faisait
trois mètres et sur l'image voilà
c'était là c'était là revient j'ai les
mêmes à la maison
c'était là voilà je vais retrouver donc
c'est celui là voilà le seul office donc
ils disent qu'il faisait trois mètres et
en fait il veut le dire trois mètres de
long je suppose ce qui est possible avec
la queue du moins ça de faut vraiment
qu'il ait une très longue queue mais
voilà trois mètres mais du coup sur
l'image et 10 3 m de haut
voilà il ya un moment où il parle de
bois fossile est ce qu'il montre à
l'écran c'est des vertèbres
bon il ya des petites coquilles comme ça
qu'ils montrent qu'ils ont pas w double
check et leur leurs informations c'est
un peu dommage mais mais c'est quand
même très agréable et ça le grand
avantage du coup je disais hé bien de
parler du registre de la sainte-victoire
là ça parle des empreintes de plagne
voilà la plus longue piste de dinosaures
découverts au monde et qui se trouve
dans le jura en france et plus loin ça
parle des oeufs de dinosaures de la
montagne sainte victoire avec thierry
tortosa du muséum d'aix en provence 8 et
bien évidemment puisqu'on parle de c'est
pas sorcier je ne peux pas ne pas parler
de c'est pas sorcier c'est pas sorcier
et notamment l'épisode qu'ils avaient
fait justement sur ans jacques donc le
l'authentic c'est pas sorcier le vrai et
l'épisode qui s'appelait les dinosaures
sous nos pieds qui se trouve sur youtube
et qui était lui aussi dédié enregistre
paléontologique français
voilà donc pareil il se passe à angeac
vous voyez les fouilleurs d'angeac en
pleine action
mais bon bah évidemment ça remonte déjà
à voyez que ça a été applaudi en mai
2013 mais bon c'est toujours d'actualité
et c'était c'est très intéressant
c'était un des derniers c'est pas
sorcier une des dernières saisons de
c'est pas sorcier et évidemment c'est
pas sorcier a fait plein d'autres pleins
d'autres vidéos sur les dinosaures donc
si vous suffit de taper c'est pas
sorcier dinosaures et voilà quoi ces
parties 1
vous en trouverez vous en trouverez des
mille et des cents évidemment n'allait
pas sûr sur d'autres documentaires c'est
pas aller sur c'est pas sorcier parce
que c'est pas sorcier ça a toujours été
bon ça toujours été bien fait voilà et
si vous voulez savoir sur d'autres
choses
il ya d'autres sujets évidemment dans
c'est pas sorcier les hommes
préhistoriques donc voilà encore une
fois c'est pour les enfants pour les
adultes du coup maintenant les grands
enfants parmi nous et bien il y a 6 ans
grand format qui a fait un documentaire
très récent voit la science grand format
il ya même une chaîne qui a fait ce
documentaire très récemment la grande
histoire de l'évolution animale
voilà très intéressant documentaire qui
a au moins un avantage de ne pas parler
que de dinosaures il parle aussi de
mammifères et notamment de l'évolution
des proboscidiens encore une fois
l'évolution des éléphants que moi même
je n'ai pas osé aborder
je n'ai toujours pas osé aborder donc
voilà il ya l'évolution des éléphants
l'évolution des oiseaux l'évolution des
cétacés dans ce reportage d'une heure 23
minutes et 56 secondes et j'étais très
très satisfait je les regardais en ayant
une oreille extrêmement critique sur ce
que sur les informations qu'ils
délivrent est et je n'ai pas été déçue
parce que c'est que du bon et c'est sur
la chaîne de bonbons amis parlons
évolution
qui fait aussi de très bonnes vidéos
donc au passage aller voir sa chaîne
c'est vraiment une chaîne très
intéressante
je le salue aussi puisque je sais qu'il
regardera probablement cette vidéo
ensuite alors une un reportage qui m'a
beaucoup amusé ces autopsies d'un t-rex
autopsie d'un t-rex qui normalement est
aussi atone et sciences grand format
aussi fait la vérité sur le t-rex
je n'ai pas encore vu la vérité sur le
t-rex dont je ne vous le recommande pas
tout de suite mais si ça vous intéresse
vous pouvez allez voir c'est un autre
science grand format la vérité sur le
t-rex d'oncle autopsie d'un t-rex qu
alors c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant parce que en fait
justement comme je le disais mon énorme
l'énorme problème que j'ai avec les
documentaires c'est qu'on nous montre
jamais l'épreuve est là en gros ils font
l'autopsié d'un t-rex donc il vous
montre les preuves au fur à mesure alors
certaines de ces preuves sont fabriqués
évidemment quand il vous montre le coeur
du t-rex on n'a jamais trouvé de coeur
fossilisés naturex
mais comme elles sont mais à chaque fois
du coup il vous explique d'où on pense
que le coeur du t-rex était comme ça ou
d'où l'on pense que les intestins du
t-rex était comme ça etc etc dont qu'ils
expliquent vraiment pas à pas au fur et
à mesure de l'autopsié d'où sortent les
informations qu'ils ont donc c'est très
très fortement mise en scène comme vous
pouvez voir donc c'est vraiment un
docu-fiction faut pas se tromper un
cetain 200% documentaire ce n'est pas
vrai t-rex dois-je vraiment le dire mais
voilà c'est vraiment un docu fiction
mais on vous parle de toutes les preuves
et pour vous dire ils sont tellement
anxieux à propos des preuves
ils sont tellement voulu mettre
l'épreuve en avant qu'en fait l'autopsié
démarre en coupant une jambe
ce qui est complètement ridicule c'est
complètement ridicule dans le cadre
d'une autopsie de commencer par couper
une jambe mais ils veulent vous montrez
l'estrie de croissance donc
donc c'est quand même quelque chose de
ils veulent vous montrez l'estrie de
croissance et ça c'est quelque chose que
ferait un paléontologue pour donner
l'âge du tyrannosaure d'un tyrannosaure
d'un os de tyrannosaure évidemment alors
qu'un l'âge d'un tyrannosaure vivant on
aurait d'autres moyens de de le donner
bon je sais pas exactement lesquels pour
être tout à fait honnête je ne suis pas
vétérinaire mais voilà je suis sûr qu'un
animal en chair et en os c'est quand
même beaucoup plus simple de donner son
âge qu'un animal juste en hausse mais un
animal juste en hausse et ben on lui
couperait le fémur pour compter le
nombre de cernes de croissance
donc voilà c'est exactement ça le le
fond de l'histoire quoi c'est juste
qu'ils sont ils ont tellement envie de
vous montrer les preuves dans ce
reportage
qu'ils commencent par faire un truc qui
dans le contexte d'une dissection serait
absolument ridicule
voilà c'est tout et c'est plutôt bien et
il ya des petites plumes sur notre t-rex
voilà vous voyez vous avez vu depuis
tout à l'heure tous les petits le petit
fusent sur son dos est très mignon
et qui vous montre aussi du coup qu'il
ya aussi des écailles sur le t-rex c'est
pas parce qu'on met des plumes sur un t
rex qui avait pas des cayes donc ça
colle aussi au registre fossile qu'on a
du t-rex reportage suivant reporte donc
là c'était national geographic donc
c'est de l'anglophone mais sous titrée
comme vous pouvez le voir le reportage
suivant c'est du 100% français et ça
s'appelle les mondes perdus donc sur
dailymotion il ya l'eau perle l'aube des
mammifères les mondes perdus donc
dailymotion qui va encore nous nous
gratifier de vignettes semi
pornographiques pour attirer le chaland
parce que dailymotion se prostituent
toujours pour et moi je regarde que des
reportages sur les dinosaures à sur
dailymotion alors les gens qui me disent
que ce que les vignettes s'affiche en
fonction de ce qui m'intéresse je suis
désolé mais je regarde que des trucs sur
les dinosaures sur dailymotion alors
pourquoi il me met vaiana et céline
farache je sais même pas qui c'est c'est
digne parages ceci dit elle a un très
beau maillot de bain bon bref donc
l'émeute les mondes perdus production
100% française alors du coup les effets
spéciaux ils sont moins bien que sur une
production américaine évidemment mais
encore une fois ça ça passe beaucoup de
temps à interviewer des chercheurs
français donc ça vous permet de
découvrir
notre beau cheptel de chercheur en
paléontologie en france et ça passe
beaucoup de temps à vous montrer les
vraies fausses il encore une fois donc
un des choses très intéressant il ya je
sais plus s'il ya trois ou cinq épisodes
en tout mais voilà et c'est une
production
c'est une production arte voyez vous
voyez que c'est à moitié en allemand à
moitié en français donc ce qui est
caractéristique des productions art et
généralement je viens de voir là je
viens de relancer une vidéo sur
dailymotion je viens de voir voilà ça
c'est le générique
donc voilà si vous cherchez les monts le
les mondes perdus le générique c'est ça
voilà évidemment vous pouvez aussi les
achetées tout à fait légalement vous
n'avez pas vous n'êtes pas obligé de les
trouver les deux les maths et
gratuitement
mais ceci dit puisque ils sont là et
ensuite le petit dernier le petit
dernier ce sera notre part animale notre
part animale qui a été qui fait partie
de ces reportages qui ont été
horriblement victimes de leur traduction
parce que notre part animale à la base
seniors i n'affiche donc votre poisson
un intérieur
enfin il ya trois épisodes il ya le
votre poisson intérieur il ya votre
votre reptiles intérieur et il y à votre
primates intérieur voilà donc ça c'est
les 3 épisodes de notre part animale moi
j'aime bien votre reptiles intérieur où
le reptile en nous parce que parce que
parce que il parlait d' été rapide de
l'afrique du sud
voilà donc ni le tube in sniil club et
s'est animée par neil turbine qui est un
véritable paléontologue et qui est le
découvreur de tiktaalik donc pour le
coup c'est vraiment cdu c'est du pile
poil quoi c'est exactement ce qu'il vous
faut pour passer un bon moment en
famille à part les fossiles et ses
essais magnifiquement orchestré avec de
très très beaux effets spéciaux puisque
évidemment cet américain voilà vous
allez voir un petit peu quelques
quelques-unes des reconstructions qui
sont faites ces moitiés effets spéciaux
moitié animations voyez
et c'est vraiment très très didactique
quoi ce mois j'ai beaucoup aimé et
encore une fois c'est tout basée sur les
preuves
y'a rien qui sort de nulle part et là
pour le coup c'est pas du tout un docu
fiction c'est 100% documentaire donc
c'est vraiment très bien et neil
chauvine présente ça vraiment de façon
excellente et très didactique donc c'est
accessible aux enfants
c'est un peu chaud 1 pour un enfant mais
bon en même temps les enfants ils
arrivent à retenir tous les noms de
dinosaures ils peuvent bien retenir de
trois structures anatomiques quand même
et donc si avec tout ça ça vous occupe à
vos longues soirées de réveillon
ben je vois pas ce qu'il vous faut parce
que ça fait quand même déjà beaucoup ça
fait un moment que je vous parle
évidemment c'est ma sélection à moi mais
si j'ai oublié votre documentaire favori
votre petit chouba n'hésitez pas à le
mettre dans les commentaires donc voilà
passer de bonnes vacances
amusez vous bien avec tous ces
reportages et je vous dis à très bientôt
sur entracte aux sciences
[Musique]